in the markets of Taiwan's capital city
Taipei you can find seemingly every
creature and it's not just choice meat
that's for sale but nearly every other
animal part as well
the Chinese sometimes complain their
countrymen will eat anything
very little is taboo and if there's one
Taiwanese gourmet who can turn the most
exotic fare into a delicacy fit for an
emperor it is chef ping Ching Cho mr.
Cho may be Taiwan's most highly
respected chef and tonight he will host
a very unusual dinner for some very
special guests including several of
taiwan's top food critics the dish she's
chosen to prepare is so taboo it may be
one of the few things many Chinese
refuse to eat the penis of the bull
country ventano so this was freshly
killed today yes it was killed this
morning this is one entree that
challenges the diners and the chef alike
if not prepared well
the meat is sinewy and tough and inside
is the Bulls urinary tract you have to
cut it open and wash it clean if you
don't then you'll have the taste of
urine in your food could this really be
a meal prized for centuries by Chinese
emperors traditionally it was considered
a potent aphrodisiac the Chinese version
of viagra for help with his recipe chef
Joe is turning to his friend dr. Zen Yi
Li a specialist in Chinese medicine dr.
Li knows exactly what combination of
herbs to prescribe to complement
is bull penis more effective than viagra
oh yes as soon as it hits the tongue the
bull penis jump-starts the brain and
enhances sexual desire I guarantee we're
going to make that very happy
chef Cho leaves the herbs to steep in
one pot while he stews the meat in
another it will take four hours to cook
for the Chinese a chef is like a doctor
and every meal is considered preventive
medicine here nearly every item is
believed to have a specific effect on
the body the Chinese believe that what
you eat is what you treat so if you eat
a pig's brain then you will treat a
human's brain likewise even a Bulls
penis is thought to increase blood flow
to the genitals and boost a man stamina
for sex people don't eat these things
every day you just couldn't take it in
his kitchen in Taiwan
chef Cho is finishing four hours of work
and he's ready to welcome his guests
among them are the leaders of Taiwan's
premier keulen Area associations men and
women who can make or break a chef's
reputation even for these experts this
meal will be a rare treat most of them
have never eaten bull penis before still
no one wants to be the first to dig in
even in Taiwan there are food taboos
that can make connoisseurs hesitate it's
a little scary but soon the verdict is
in it's just like eating a piece of beef
with tendons that is why chef Cho is so
great he was able to serve bull penises
in such a way that you can't tell which
part of the penis you're eating it's
high praise with his power to transform
the taboo into the tantalizing chef Cho
may win new converts to this ancient
delicacy diners who may seek it out not
just for romantic and medicinal effects
but also for its taste